on this saturday night
the scramble to get back to canada
canadians abroad rush to get home i find
that just a little
annoying after the government cancels
flights and issues
new quarantine rules the businesses
defying health orders
we're all up in arms and the politicians
supporting them
plus the new industrial revolution the
rise of robotics in the home delivery
boom
and the gift that keeps on giving to a
canadian
centenarian
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us the federal government insists
airlines are working to get canadians
abroad back home
many flights to popular sun destinations
are being cancelled as part of ottawa's
plan to restrict travel
and stop the spread of covet 19. the
other component is having to pay to
quarantine upon landing back in canada
so there's a frenzy to get home to avoid
the costly bill
here's mike jolet
like thousands of other canadians
escaping winter from mexico's warmth
proved too enticing for pat hall and her
husband
despite the warnings about traveling
they say they haven't felt any more at
risk of getting coveted
than they were at home in calgary
they've got quite a few rules here
actually
i find people driving even in their cars
are wearing masks
so they're taking it pretty seriously
down here
but like other canadians on vacation
down south they're booking early flights
home
all flights on canadian airlines to
mexico and the caribbean have been
canceled as of sunday
and return flights as of february 14th
and international travelers arriving in
canada will soon have no choice but to
spend two thousand dollars for a cova
test
in three days in a quarantine hotel
rules dr anna banerjee hopes will help
avoid another surge
is it too late probably not because
march break is coming up
and people are tired and uh you know we
saw what happened
during the holidays when you know they
said well um
the restrictions came in a little bit
late and so half of canada
uh engaged with people outside of their
household
so long as they pay for the quarantine
hotel nothing is stopping canadians from
traveling
there are plenty of flights leaving
toronto for cancun on monday
just none with canadian airlines and if
canadians want to fly on air canada or
westjet to california florida or hawaii
they can and yet the voters in ontario
and quebec are able to go to florida and
back without
the same kind of penalty whatsoever so
we're fine i find that just a little
annoying to be honest with you
and he's not the only one our new slogan
has been discouraged vacations
not family dr david poon fought and won
the right for unwed partners to reunite
in canada
the new rules he says paints them with
the same brush as those on vacation
and he's afraid families will once again
be split up
the people have waited months for their
visa ready to see their family
and then suddenly an extra two thousand
dollars they can't afford that mike
dralet global news toronto
alberta is introducing a new framework
that allows public health measures to be
eased
when covet 19 hospitalizations drop it
goes into effect in february but some
businesses
frustrated with the loss of money and
tired of the pandemic
are already open heather york's west
reports
in alberta restaurants have been closed
to in-person dining since mid-december
but in this central alberta town the
noble fox is bustling
it was hard decision i just said it's
i didn't take it lightly but again it's
enough is enough and i need to
make sure they hear us carlos sigenza's
business has been visited by health
officials but the small business owner
remains defiant
and he's not alone a small number of
other rural alberta eateries have opened
in protest
too even mayors for lacklubish and
bonneyville have joined the defiance
to sit down for a meal in an effort to
support these businesses
if we're all mad and we're all up in
arms about what's going on and what and
how we're being treated
they don't have any choice to listen
decisions that are being taken to open
in contravention of the orders are not
in the best interests of
our communities the message from health
officials has consistently been
one of the need for cooperation that the
sacrifice of many
is required for the common good but this
behavioral
science expert says that strategy has
limits i think with the new variants we
should look again
at considering a mix of both incentives
and disincentives so carrots and sticks
for helping to encourage people to do
good behavior that helps everybody
and that they gain from it especially
when business owners have so much at
stake
restaurants canada does not support
businesses opening in defiance of health
orders
but it also says it's not surprised to
see owners desperate to stay open
without more support it estimates nearly
half of its members
won't survive the year we've got grants
in alberta but
they don't cover anywhere near the
losses that restaurants are facing and
you know we've got the wage subsidy and
the rent subsidy which are a big help to
a lot of our members
but we still have many of them that are
falling through those eligibility cracks
the reality is even with the promise of
a vaccine the threat of kova 19 will
likely only get worse in the coming
months
unfortunately if these variants take
hold we may see further restrictions or
at least
longer term restrictions when it is
allowed to spread in the community our
healthcare system simply cannot keep up
making widespread compliance to public
health guidelines
more important now than ever heather
urex west global news
calgary in the u.s more than 26 million
people have now tested positive for
coven 19.
that's one out of every 12 americans the
biden administration is pushing congress
to pass its 1.9
trillion dollar relief package to fund a
federal vaccine program
as jennifer johnson reports fears are
growing over the variants
spreading across state lines starting
monday the centers for disease control
and prevention is making mass
mandatory on all public transportation
across the u.s
not just planes and trains but also
taxis ferries
even ride share cars another weapon to
fight the pandemic
as the biden administration pushes
congress to pass its
1.9 trillion dollar coveted relief
package which includes 20 billion for
federal vaccination centers
the cover relief has to pass there's no
offense or buts
the biden team says about one million
doses a day were administered over the
past
week they want that increase to 1.5
million a day
as weary americans await their
vaccination this weekend senior citizens
in denver were put into a pool
and randomly selected to receive ten
thousand available doses
over a half million people are on a
waiting list in dallas county
registration is critically important but
the message also needs to get out there
we need more supply vaccine supplies are
still way below demand
as new more transmissible strains of the
virus appear in at least
30 states concerns are mounting over the
latest one detected in south carolina
we are in particular very worried about
the south african variant
because it appears to make vaccines less
effective
federal officials are working with the
state's health department to try and
stop the spread of that strain
with resources for increased testing
increased surveillance
as well as increased resources for
vaccination and funding
as hospitalizations start to level off
states are again reopening some
businesses
indoor dining at 25 capacity will return
to new york on valentine's day
outdoor dining is back in los angeles
county at 50 percent capacity
after a two-month pause it won't be
summertime busy down here but it'll be
busy i think everyone's going to come
out they've been cooped up they haven't
been able to have that restaurant
experience
but experts warn this latest reopening
phase may be short-lived
if new strains of the virus continue
their rapid spread
jennifer johnson global news washington
in europe tonight new border
restrictions are going into effect to
slow the spread of kova 19 and its new
strains
starting tomorrow in france all travel
from outside the eu will be banned with
the exception of truckers coming from
the uk
those entering from a european country
must have a coveted test
and germany has banned travelers from
countries where the new variants have
been detected
including the uk and ireland
the world health organization is
criticizing the european union for
adding export controls
on covet 19 vaccines the who says the
new measures could cause supply
chain disruptions that ripple around the
world and potentially
prolong the pandemic let's say it's not
helpful
to have any country at this stage
putting export bans or barriers that
will not allow for the free uh
movement of the the necessary
ingredients that will make vaccines
diagnostics
in other medicines available to all
the world the new measures allow the eu
to deny vaccine exports if the
manufacturer has not honored existing
contracts with blocked nations
the controls impact about 100 countries
worldwide
the eu says the measures are temporary
and not
an export ban late this afternoon
canada's international trade minister
sent out this tweet saying
she spoke to her eu counterpart today
and was reassured that canada's vaccine
shipments
will not be affected by the new measures
israel facing criticism for not
including palestinians in its aggressive
vaccine rollout
is now changing that a government source
confirmed to global news
israel will transfer 5 000 doses of the
pfizer biontech vaccine to the
palestinian authority
in order to vaccinate 2500 medical
workers
the shots are due to be delivered to the
west bank early next week
it's not clear whether any of the shots
will be given to health workers in the
densely populated
gaza strip which is controlled by hamas
and subject to a blockade
there have been more than 158 000 cases
of coven 19
in the two palestinian territories since
the pandemic
began these vaccines are the lifeline
canadians need to protect themselves but
canada has been dealt a blow with delays
moderna will ship only about three
quarters of canada's next shipment
cutting next week's delivery by more
than 50 000 doses
pfizer is shipping roughly 80 fewer
shots than it initially promised
over the next month mercedes stevenson
joins us to talk about how these delays
impact the people
on the front lines mercedes
robin last week there were zero pfizer
vaccines delivered to canada and on
friday we learned that there will be a
drop in the moderna deliveries by 20 to
25 percent over the month of february
the head of the canadian medical
association says these setbacks
are demoralizing and distressing for
doctors
the messaging around this is
it's upsetting and it's confusing not
only to health care providers but
to canadians in general it is
distressing to hear
that there's been a decrease in the
anticipated
dose delivery numbers in the next coming
weeks
both from pfizer and more recently today
from moderna
and yet we keep hearing messaging from
the prime minister that
uh things are on track everything will
be still
as it should be by the end of march and
and of course that doesn't really add up
dr collins added that it's critical to
ensure
health care workers and physicians get
the vaccine
so they can remain on the front lines to
go back to battle against the virus
she also said that doctors want to be
confident in the government's efforts to
procure vaccines
but she reiterated twice that the math
just doesn't seem to add up
the government asserts that all
canadians who want to get a vaccine
will be able to by the end of september
robin
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes coming up a canadian
olympic champion loses her medals in a
fire
we are learning more tonight about the
members of a toronto family killed in a
house fire
four people died including a young child
the family was part of a tight-knit
community
and the deaths are having a devastating
impact here's morgan campbell
the memorial grows outside of this
burned out toronto home
and i sit there thinking about the war i
don't know i'm dying that way
people still coming to terms with the
aftermath of friday's fire
in the city's east end the flames
overwhelming the residents
killing four people and injuring two
others
global news has learned several
generations of the same family
lived in the home the owner aria
janssen's along with her son
and grandmother it's heart wrecking it's
it's terrifying i i saw the footage and
flames coming like i lived in that
window and it's uh
yeah it's tough friends say jansen
survived the fire
and is recovering in hospital her son
died from his injuries the investigation
is multi-faceted and
fire officials say they expect to remain
here on scene for the next several days
trying to determine
what exactly sparked the blaze we are
collectively have to answer the
questions
deputy chief larry coco says
investigators are trying to determine
whether the home had working smoke
alarms among other things
all factors surrounding the occupancy
its use
and what was occurring will form part of
that again
it's an active investigation and we're
collecting all that information
several firefighters were also injured
including one who fell through the floor
and another who was caught in what is
called a flashover
the temperatures inside the house rose
to the point where everything in the
house became
flammable and burst into flames and
you have when that happens it's you have
seconds to get yourself to a safe spot
the scene tragic and hard to comprehend
for those wanting to know what happened
and why
i don't really want to sit there and try
and think it to feel it because i
have a chance to process this morgan
campbell global news toronto
canadian olympic diver megan benfido and
her boyfriend
alexander dupuy who plays with
edmonton's cfl team
have lost everything in a fire benfitto
was home alone in their montreal condo
when a neighbor's barbecue
blew up and set the building ablaze she
managed to escape
but the fire destroyed all their
belongings including her three olympic
medals
and two medals won at the pan am games
on instagram the couple says to
appreciate the things you have
they might be gone in a minute
still ahead it's been dubbed industry
4.0
is canada ready for this revolution
you're watching global national
whether ordering takeout or buying
toilet paper since the start of the
covet 19 pandemic
canadians have relied on home delivery
like never before
but as these demands increase so does
the need for greater efficiency
in bringing goods from the warehouse
floor to your door
many economists see this as an
opportunity for canadian industries to
embrace
automation mike delay looks into whether
canada is ready to invest
in a new industrial revolution
this is soby's big bet the most complex
and advanced merging of ai and robotics
in a canadian grocery store chain it
cost 100 million dollars
and they couldn't be happier they move
four meters a second
you know they are just zipping past it
takes your breath away
it you realize that there's nothing
quite that productive in the world
sobe's decided to make a technological
shift in its warehouse and home delivery
system two years ago
a move that seems prescient now
considering the millions of canadians
working from home
with online orders up three hundred
percent they're now planning new hubs in
alberta and quebec and then another down
the road
with four of these facilities across the
country we can get within 75
percent of the canadian population and
actually more impressively
90 percent of the expected e-commerce
spend
what sobes is doing is what economists
argue canada needs more of to flourish
post-pandemic
the wide scale implementation of ai
machine learning in robots
is being called industry 4.0 or the
fourth industrial revolution
some would argue automation is a risk
for the loss of jobs alone with
advancements in ai driverless
buses and computer-generated media
influencers once thought to be
impossible
are now reality callous papers have been
written on the subject of which jobs are
most likely to become obsolete stats
canned reports the top three to be
office support
the service industry and construction
trades
computers and artificial intelligence
have become better at organizing and
taking orders so
it just makes sense but it doesn't tell
the whole story
because for all the talk about
technology canada might not be fully
ready for it
automation consultant ben angel says
massive investment is needed at the
warehouse level
well our factories are actually well
automated that happened
you know the assembly line that was
automated 20 25 years ago
so our canadian factories are well
automated
no issues with that but it's when that
product is made when it's moving
to the warehouse our warehouses are full
of forklifts
canadian companies love their forklifts
the good news is the country's colleges
and universities are addressing the
issue
by offering automation and mechatronic
courses
if change starts with education canada
is hopefully now
on the right course mike drollet global
news toronto
and to learn why the future of canada's
post-pandemic growth is going to be so
dependent upon robotics and artificial
intelligence
watch the new reality tonight on global
it's a special day in beaver harbor new
brunswick up next the big birthday
getting
global attention
according to a recent u.s study about
one in one
thousand people who reached the age of a
hundred can live to a hundred and ten
today one of the oldest canadians became
one of them
because of the pandemic the new
brunswick man can't mark the milestones
surrounded by loved ones at a party
so his family found another way to make
his big day special
safely travis sportnum explains
dubbed canada's grandpa new brunswicker
arnold hawkins
is now 110 years old i just can't
believe he's still here
happy birthday the usual open house
party that's proven to be a hot ticket
since he hit the century milestone
just couldn't happen in pandemic times
so
his family went looking for another way
to celebrate
a friend of ours say why don't you put
his address
in case somebody wants to send a card by
making a public
ask for birthday cards a lot of birthday
cards i thought maybe we could hit the
110 if i just posted on his facebook
page
just kind of exploded with the big day
here
hogan's granddaughter says they've
received more than
5 000 and counting from places
far and wide we have all the atlantic
provinces here
right straight across canada to alberta
and bc saskatchewan
like everywhere northwest territories
we've got
australia we've got germany in the uk
everywhere
schools senior homes long lost family
but mostly strangers
the stories that people are sending us
you know with about
their own families and it's just pretty
amazing
like they're sending so many messages
and saying how
uplifting it is to them his super
centerian smile
a symbol of hope in trying times
i don't know what to say it might take
me till his birthday
next year when he's 110 i might still be
a reading card to him
travis fortnum global news beaver harbor
new brunswick
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is pyramid mountain
in jasper national park we'd love to see
your corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching have a great
night
you